Gentlemen if you want to sell
a couple hundred thousand game boys to little kids,
package it with Mario.
But if you want to sell millions to absolutely everyone
around the world,
package it with Tetris.
Tetris?
It’s the perfect game.
It's an extraordinary story
involving lots of different factions
from all over the world
all pursuing this incredibly hot property.
This game is poetry,
art and math all working in magical synchronicity.
My character Henk is a publisher of games
who sets out on this kind of mad dash
to secure the rights to Tetris.
Where?
Russia.
There's this one man in the USSR
whose made this thing that everyone wants.
Alexey is the designer,
he designed the game.
Because of the laws in Russia at the time,
he's denied the right to earn any money
from his game, it kind of becomes the property of the state.
But Henk kind of storms into his life.
Henk was the first man in Russia
to whom you can talk about computers.
I'm going to make you a millionaire.
I do not have right to receive money from my game.
That’s criminal.
No,
it is communism.
Have you ever negotiated with the Soviets Mr. Rogers?
Do you know what it feels like to be
in a country where everyone is watching you?
Go home, understood?
How do you get the game out of Russia
when everything's chaos there?
This is an illegal copy.
He thinks I stole Tetris?
Affirmative.
These were true visionaries that
broke the rules to make the world better.
It's an unknown story about a very well known game.
Henk hits a number of walls trying to
smuggle the rights of Tetris out of the USSR
one of those blockades being the Maxwell's.
Kevin Maxwell, CEO of Mirrorsoft.
Fantastic,
I would like to buy your worldwide handheld rights.
We'll consider your offer, Mr. Rogers.
I haven’t made one yet.
Yes.
It's exciting, it's thrilling,
it's based on reality, it's just a lot of fun.
Not so often I can see the movie
when I read the screenplay but
this one was brilliant.
Get me Tetris.
It's about companionship and friendship
and that these two kindred spirits,
capitalists and communists have kind of come together.
My dad put everything on the line
to chase after this game,
most people have no idea the drama the game went through
for it to spread to the rest of the world.
I think some people will feel nostalgic.
Tetris has connection to this desire that all human beings
have to create something, to build something,
to put everything in order.
This phrase falling blocks it's about love,
it doesn't matter where you're from, if you're inspired
by what you're doing there are no barriers.
Tetris is a cultural zeitgeist.
And it's quite exciting to think that the backstory
to this phenomenon will finally
get its moment in the sunlight.